- [Narrator] A rapidly
growing financial trend
is attempting to turn
traditional banking on its head.
It's called decentralized
finance, or DEFI.
And it promises to bring digital banking
for cryptocurrencies to the masses,
but with no middlemen and
almost no barriers to entry.
- So in the last 18 months,
this idea has really mushroomed
within the crypto market.
- [Narrator] Estimates vary,
but a conservative one says
the total value locked in DEFI
reached $114 billion
in November this year.
And while that's just a fraction
compared with traditional
banking, DEFI is growing quickly.
It has increased more than
1,200% since June, 2020.
Here's why some are calling
DEFI the Wild West of finance,
where investors are
entering uncharted territory
to take on big risks for the
chance of even bigger rewards.
When we talk about DEFI, we're not talking
about a specific financial
product or service.
- DEFI is just the next iteration
of this grand experiment
in cryptocurrencies,
which is basically just to recreate
the financial system in
a digital online format.
- [Narrator] Paul Vigna has been reporting
on the equities market
for almost 25 years,
and has been covering
cryptocurrencies since 2013.
- Anything you could do
at a bank or a brokerage
is handled rather than
through an individual
and a corporation, it's handled
through a computer program.
- [Narrator] You can think
of the emergence of DEFI
like this, a dusty town
in the wild American West,
where there's no sheriff,
no bank, and no cash.
Here at the local Trading Post,
people can trade and lend goods,
and do pretty much anything
else normally done at a bank.
It isn't owned by a
single person or entity.
And unlike traditional finance,
trades that happen here
are verified out in the
open where everyone can see.
For example, one type of transaction
that takes place at the
Trading Post is lending.
To ensure the trade,
the borrower gives
collateral for the loan.
The lender then earns
interest off this deal
in the same way a bank would.
Transactions like this are all
recorded on a public ledger
that everyone can see.
In the world of DEFI, this
ledger is called a blockchain,
which is a network of computers
built to store and record transactions.
- Every computer on that network
has an identical copy of that ledger,
so that all of the data is
open, all of it is public.
- [Narrator] This is different
from a traditional stock
trade, which works like this.
- I have a broker, the
other party has a broker,
the company has an institution
that keeps track of the stock itself.
All these different middlemen,
all these different intermediaries
have their own ledgers,
have their own internal databases
where they're recording the transactions.
A blockchain takes care of all of that
and does it in an open way
that anybody can track the
progress of that trade.
- [Narrator] Most DEFI services
run on Ethereum's technology,
which also hosts the cryptocurrency Ether.
It's one of the most commonly
traded cryptos in DEFI,
along with stablecoins, digital assets,
which are pegged to
currencies, like the dollar.
The DEFI services run on the blockchain,
similar to how apps run on your phone.
And the mechanism that allows them to work
is called a smart contract.
- Smart contract as an idea
have been around for years.
It's another app that is
focused on a bank-like service.
So all it's really doing
is taking all the parameters of a trade
and sticking them into
fields and automating it
and then monitoring it.
- [Narrator] Smart contracts
are designed to give DEFI transactions
more transparency and security.
- And because all the
parameters were being inputted
into a program, ostensibly
it's more secure
because there shouldn't be any
real debate or contradiction
about the terms of the service.
- [Narrator] Despite
this layer of security,
decentralized finance
carries a lot of risk.
In many cases,
the people facilitating DEFI
transactions are anonymous.
This has caused fraud to become rampant.
A poorly created smart
contract could have loopholes
that allow scammers to steal
or other design flaws that
affect the value of assets.
Another risk is security.
And because most DEFI
services aren't insured,
if a platform fails or is hacked,
millions of dollars can be on the line.
- The problem is that you may not know
who wrote the program.
You may not know how secure
the program itself is.
That's a significant, significant risk
that you really can't overlook.
These DEFI protocols
virtually once a week,
there is a problem with one of them.
- [Narrator] So far this year,
investors have lost about one
and a half billion dollars
to DEFI attacks, hacks, and cons.
And in this Wild West of finance,
regulation is still
virtually non-existent,
though, that could change.
Here's the chairman
of the Securities and Exchange Commission
speaking with The Wall
Street Journal about DEFI.
- But if this field is gonna have
an ability to move forward,
it's gonna be inside some
public policy framework
and inside some sort of
regulatory perimeter.
Look, folks have already
been hurt in this field.
- [Narrator] While
decentralized finance is risky,
many think the potential
benefits are worth it.
- The benefits are an
ability to make money.
You are either lending
out your cryptocurrencies
and you're getting
interest paid back on that,
and that interest can be
anywhere from 5% to 20%,
even more.
You can be a passive investor
and earn money on an asset
that you were probably storing in a wallet
that was doing nothing.
The other benefit is you can
borrow against your holdings.
A lot of these services are being used
as a way for people to get a
bigger pool of cryptocurrency
to go through a bets out
into the derivatives market.
So it's a way for you to turbocharge
your cryptocurrency
gambling habit, essentially.
- [Narrator] If DEFI continues growing,
it's likely that
regulations will be imposed
to smooth out its rough edges
and reduce risk for investors,
which makes sense.
Even in the wildest of Wild West towns,
a sheriff eventually showed
up to lay down the law.
(light music)